[Musik]
ja
und damit herzlich willkommen hier zum
heutigen video meine lieben freunde ich
habe mir gedacht passen zum jahr 2020
spielen wir ein spiel namens von bonnie
da kann man nämlich auf das jahr 2020
kann auch richtig viel packen
man kann auch wissen jetzt auch mal
ruhig sein dann eine stunde später
ja ich weiß es nicht
das jetzt gemacht
ja die ist aber nicht kleben doch aha
wenn er wieder weg jetzt ha ha mir ist
halt auch wichtig dass die qualität
wirklich dann noch mal stimmt hier im
letzten video dieses jahr wieder lieben
freunde spaß beiseite das jahr 2020 mal
wirklich kacke
deswegen dachte ich mir passt mich an
die heutigen video ich will jetzt gar
nicht das video künstlich in die länge
ziehen oder noch ein anderes spiel jetzt
irgendwie anzogen oder was auch mit dem
jahr 2020 zu tun hat und keine ahnung
was denn ich möchte jetzt wieder einfach
nur nutzen um euch dennoch dankeschön zu
sagen dieses jahr 2020 glaubt wir haben
uns das alle haben uns alle dieses jahr
nicht so vorgestellt wie es dann
schlussendlich gekommen ist
das richtiges deutsch jedoch habe ich
sehr viel mitnehmen können aus diesem
jahr und das bezieht sich auch auf
youtube und dementsprechend auch auf
euch meine lieben freunde meine liebe
nur deswegen wollte ich jetzt einfach
nur mal kurz danke sagen danke für
dieses jahr 2020 auch wenn es nicht so
war wie es uns vorgestellt haben wir
glaube ich alle versuchen das beste
draus machen
daumen drücken dass 2021 besser wird
welchen guten rutsch und
rutscht nicht aus
[Musik]